my observation of your book you know
you've interviewed a lot of people that
didn't come from wealth yeah you
included and and when you're looking at
the commonalities between all of them
how to invest and I'm looking at the
typical person right now trying to save
in their 401K none of you all in that
book really saved you guys all invest
right right well look they're different
things so their book was written for
this was a book called how to invest and
obviously you're not going to read that
book and become Warren Buffett just like
you're not going to read a book by
um Tiger Woods have become a great
golfer you can't read a book and all of
a sudden change your life that
dramatically but this is designed for
young students who want to consider a
career investing or for the average
person and not the superstars uh for the
average person who has a reasonable
amount of excess income they probably
shouldn't try to be Warren Buffett by
all of a sudden picking stocks
themselves picking bonds themselves they
probably should give their money to a
money manager and probably best to put
it in an index fund which will track the
market because the average person who
makes fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars a year is not gonna
quadruple group or their net worth by
picking stocks here and there you're
just not going to beat the market
averages so be with the market average
and be the go with an index fund there's
a low fee that's what the average person
should really do in my view when you
interviewed uh Mary calendar and Erdos
right she she goes on record saying that
you know there's 2200 analysts starting
there's a two or three year training
program and if you're going to master
something 10 000 hours if you're going
to work at typical job it's going to
take you five years to master something
she goes on record by saying in Wall
Street it's 12 hours a day six days a
week in two to three years you'll Master
something she got a lot of pushback
because of that are we in a generation
right now where people don't want to put
in the work and put in the effort to
start mastering things I think they're
always going to be people with ambition
and always people want to get ahead in
life at least in this country some
people may rebel against that there are
some people in the youngest generation
who now say look I want to work 20 hours
a week on work from home and I'm not
going to the office and but you know
those people will be left behind in my
view I think there are people ambitious
who want to
get ahead in life Mary Erdos for those
who don't know runs to JP Morgan private
wealth business which is roughly a four
trillion dollar business and she's
managing money for the wealthiest people
in the country she's a heavyweight she's
not just anybody she's a serious person
and uh one of the you know I tried in
the book to make it clear you don't have
to be an old white man to be an
investment professional who's good so I
had uh people from Minority backgrounds
people are women and I and I think
there'll be more of them if I wrote this
book 10 years from now there might not
be that many white males in it because
the business is changing
so with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bright
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]